so one example of again the common trend
of women never being happy
as Larissa Pippen you know Larissa
Pittman was married to a superstar she
had her
bills taking care of the rest of her
life
yet what what did she do she decided to
divorce her husband she decided to post
super provocative pictures on Instagram
and now she's dating a guy 17 years
younger than her that was friends with
her son so Michael Jordan's son Marcus
Jordan reveals that him and Larissa
Pippin are now planning their wedding so
guys look at the woman on the left she's
got these claw fingernails she's in a
bikini right
um no shirt on uh clearly a bunch of
Botox plastic surgery oh the these women
it's so funny because you can't even
tell the difference between wives and
mothers and single women they look
exactly the same